- I got my merch on.
Do you have your merch on?
We're about to watch the Rocky movies,
talk about some of the health effects
that my man Rocco has faced.
Let's get into it.
Be woo!
Hey, yo, Rocco.
I never understood why boxers
did this back in the day,
or frankly, any athletes.
I can't help but think about
salmonella falling into his cup right now.
'Cause I bet those are not
pasteurized in shell eggs.
He doesn't look like he was
fancy enough to be buying those.
And salmonella,
you can go many eggs without getting it.
I think the statistic
is one in 20,000 eggs
contains salmonella,
but that one time you get it,
you're gonna wish you didn't.
Also, I believe that
there's a fact out there,
eating raw eggs decreases
your ability to absorb biotin
which is good for hair, skin and nails.
- [News Anchor] Well, we deserve it.
We've been getting away with murder
for the last couple of weeks.
Our high today could possibly be.
- Why are you spilling
it on your shirt, guy?
(Rocky grunting)
Whoa.
This is so unnecessary.
Not only is he punching raw meat
that should be used for
human eating consumption,
but he's also punching ribs,
hurting his knuckles
because he doesn't have boxing gloves on.
As any boxer would know,
an injury to your knuckles
is an injury to your
boxing career, potentially.
(Rocky grunting)
- You're breaking the ribs.
(doctor laughing)
- Also, he's throwing punches
in kind of like a weird form.
I don't know what that is.
He's not like throwing a straight shot.
He's not throwing a hook.
He's kind of like doing some kind of
in between overhand thing.
Those wraps smell like death.
Look, we have the same beanie
on except mine's merch.
Link down below to sign up
for the new merch release,
coming soon.
- You lay off that pet shop dame.
Women weaken legs.
- The scientific accuracy
of that statement
just has never been proven to be true.
Whether you look at hormone levels,
you look at performance,
it just, there is no pattern
that has emerged there.
And I'll tell you why.
'Cause I don't think it's women,
I don't think it's sex.
I think it's the act of getting boozed up,
stressed out, staying up late.
That's what weakens the legs,
but it's not the women or
the sex that's causing it.
I call misinformation on that one.
Look at 'em on the speed bag.
Yeah, Rocco!
(inspirational montage music)
That's actually really hard.
There's an element of plyometrics there.
Shoulder strengthening,
core strengthening.
A lot of stuff is happening there.
This is really impressive.
Core training for boxing is so important
because not only are you needing
the ability to absorb hits,
but you also need the
ability to turn your body.
That's how you develop strength in boxing.
Can someone get this guy
a proper punching bag?
The cows need a break!
That kind of exercise on the stairs
is obviously the iconic Rocky moment.
And while I think stairs
are a great exercise,
I think it trains your
lower body extremely well,
your cardiovascular system extremely well,
I prefer doing like the aero bike to that
because you're getting an
upper and lower body workout
and a HIIT workout at the same time.
Ooh.
- Your nose is broken.
- Nasal fractures are
a very common injury,
especially in boxing.
40 to 50% of facial
fractures happen in the nose.
But two things can happen.
You could form a septal hematoma,
which is blood pooling in the area,
causing immense pressure problems
and it actually needs to be drained.
And then the second
thing that could happen
is you could have a fracture
of your cribriform plate
where you actually start
leaking cerebral spinal fluid,
also known as CSF.
Ooh.
Right body shots are brutal,
'cause not only do you have
the potential for breaking someone's ribs,
which obviously is extremely painful,
hurts your ability to rotate,
hurts your ability to breathe,
but also because your liver's there
and a shot to the liver,
with its unique position within the body
and its unique relationship
with the nervous system
and the circulatory system,
a shot to the liver will bring you down.
- I can't see nothing.
Gotta open my eye.
Cut me, Mick.
- I don't wanna do it.
- Go on, cut me.
Cut me.
- Okay, try it.
(Rocky grunting)
- This is such a terrible scene.
Okay, so we no longer do this.
What's happening here is he
has a hematoma over his eye,
swelling, blood pooling.
And essentially he's saying cut it open
so the fluid can leak out
and I can actually open my eye and see.
That was done incredibly not safe.
He didn't even disinfect the area first.
That's gonna be a problem.
Nowadays, this is not legal.
Cut men are not actually cutting you.
They're actually stopping
cuts from bleeding
and gauging on whether or not
the cut is dangerous to the
person's life or vital organs.
- Come on, Rocky!
Go on and get him.
Get him, get him, get him.
Come on, what's the matter with ya?
Get him!
- But there's better ways to do training
than torturing a poor
chicken running around.
There's just exercises you could do
where you don't need to chase a chicken.
- My husband and I thank you for
coming to our training quarter today.
- Well, hello, my fellow
Russian immigrant.
I'm glad to face you.
- There have been rumors of blood doping
and widespread distribution
of anabolic steroids
in the Soviet Union.
Has Drago partaken in
any such experiments?
- No.
- Anabolic steroids, blood doping.
It is a real thing in professional sports.
Even though there are steps
put in place to prevent it,
like drug testing.
Russia also had a huge scandal
with anabolic steroids.
I highly recommend,
there's a documentary on
Netflix called Icarus.
Definitely check that out,
'cause it just shows
you how dirty and nasty
all of these games are behind the scenes.
(dramatic music)
- As you can see,
Drago averages 1,850 pounds.
So the result's quite obvious.
(crickets chirping)
- That he's strong?
What does the technology
have to do with it?
This guy didn't describe anything.
It looks like he created
those arcade things
that you see on TikTok
videos of people failing
and hitting the top of it
and breaking their hands.
- [Commentator] I've never seen Apollo
take so much punishment.
- Get the towel!
- No!
- Oh.
Yeah, the reason the referee
has come in and step in
or the corner has to throw
in the towel is because
the fighter no longer can
make decisions for themselves.
If you take too many punches to the head,
it's very easy to find
yourself in that position.
So if you see a fighter
that's just getting hit
repeatedly, repeatedly,
not being able to throw back
not being able to show
that he's doing any kind
of movement or action,
that puts his life in jeopardy.
That's where it gets
shut down and stopped.
- My God!
- What's interesting is that
a lot of the deadly blows
and most damaging blows in boxing
come over a period of time,
multiple blows over, over, over again,
not like that one strong knockout
that actually ends up knocking you down.
And there's a lot problems
when you start having
bleeding in the brain
because the skull is an
enclosed environment.
There's nowhere for that blood to go.
So if the person starts bleeding,
A, they're not getting blood flow
to the actual part of their
brain that's necessary,
but it also starts building up pressure,
putting more pressure on the brain,
essentially shutting
parts of the brain down.
If your brain stem shuts down,
the part that's responsible
for respiratory rate
or cardiac rate,
that shuts down, that's when you die.
- If he dies, he dies.
- Rocco, where are the chest compressions?
(hands slapping)
You don't know why he's dying.
What if he's bleeding internally
and needs some chest compressions?
Check his pulse, Rocco.
(ominous music)
I guess that guy is roiding,
but it's not clear what that was.
And earlier it was
mentioned, blood doping.
Blood doping is basically
either getting transfusions of blood,
either from yourself or from someone else,
or they give themselves
a chemical known as EPO,
erythropoietin,
which is actually a chemical
made by your kidneys
that increased the production
of red blood cells,
thereby increasing your
oxygen carrying ability.
- He's cut!
- Oh.
- He's cut.
- [Commentator] The Russian's cut!
- Russian's cut?
It's kind of a weird way to say it.
(bell ringing)
That last punch was so fake.
It was bad.
Like, he just went like this
and nothing even happened.
And there was the sound effect.
(crowd cheering)
- All right!
- Boxing actually has
this 10 count, right?
There's a person who
stands outside the ring
and actually starts the
count and holds the count.
Also once a fighter is up,
it doesn't necessarily mean
they're ready to fight.
If the referee deems
that the fighter is not
able to protect themselves,
like if the referee's like
move left, move right,
hold up your arms in front of you,
if you're unable to do that,
that means you're unable
to protect yourself.
The fight is still over.
- Rocky, you're scaring me.
What's wrong?
- I can't.
- Can't what?
- I can't stop my hands from shaking.
- I mean, maybe it's a good
time to go to the hospital?
- I'm just tired.
- Okay.
- And I just wanna go home, okay?
- At this point there
should be a ring physician
or a ringside physician
coming in, doing a neuro check,
making sure that,
neurologically, he's intact,
he's fine, he's stable.
And I don't feel like
that's happening here.
- Recently, The American
Medical Association
recommended that boxing be banned.
- Yeah?
- Do you agree with the doctor?
- Is boxing a dangerous sport
that is unhealthy for your brain?
Yes.
Is there a way to practice boxing,
practice boxing, not actually
fight, and be healthy?
Yes.
In fact, there's a lot of
healthy benefits to boxing.
When you're calculating
someone's risk in their life,
you're not just looking at one activity.
There's a lot of variables.
Those who step inside the ring
and risk getting hit in the face
and cause CTE to their
brain, they're taking a risk.
I think it's their choice.
I think a lot of people make that choice.
- You know, absolutely.
I think that doctors
should never fight, no.
- Did he just say that I shouldn't fight?
Rocco, I'm sorry buddy, but I gotta do it!
- Because of the continuous
violent blows to the head,
you've developed a condition
particular to boxers
called cavum septum pellucidum,
which is a hole in the membrane
separating the ventricles.
The brain surface neurons in this area
have also been traumatized.
- I don't even know what the
heck they're looking at here.
It says physical.
There's some kind of beautiful lines.
There's different cuts
that we're looking at here.
Maybe a functional MRI, like an early one.
The reality is the condition
they're talking about
is one that has been
associated, not proven,
to have happened with
contact sport athletes,
fighters, football players, et cetera.
It's been associated with CTE,
chronic trauma encephalopathy.
We have tied the condition
to worse mood outcomes,
worse scores,
but it's also something that
can happen during development
and be an incidental finding
and sort of like a normal
variant on imaging.
So there's still a lot of
questions to be answered.
What causes this exactly?
How does it happen?
Because there's only
theories out there so far.
And what are the implications
if it does happen
if you've never had it before?
And in fact, I know in
the future Rocky movies,
he goes back to fighting.
So clearly this wasn't a
reason for him to retire.
- I think I want to, like, do something.
- Like what?
- Fight.
(inspirational montage music)
- I don't know that you
need to squat 10 plates
in order to be a boxer.
(doctor laughing)
And he loves his raw eggs.
My man, just get some whey protein powder.
This is ridiculous.
He's literally asking to
tear his bicep by doing that.
Oh my God, he's punching the cows again.
Just, God.
(crowd cheering)
The effects got better,
but not much better.
- [Commentator] And back comes Dixon
with brutal left hand shots.
- Oh!
- [Commentator] Dickson
hurt his hand there.
- Hitting another fighter's
bone with a bad angle
is very problematic.
Elbow,
you go to hit a body shot,
the elbow hits you in
the thumb, in the wrist,
it could potentially break your hand.
Hitting someone in the hip, bad angle,
can turn the wrist, sprain it, break it.
Another one is on the skull.
You go to punch a fighter,
they tilt their skull down.
It flexes your wrist like
this, over flexes it,
potentially sprains,
tears, breaks bone here.
- How's the hand?
- My hand's broke.
My hand's broke.
That's it, throw in the fight.
There's no need to continue.
- What did you said to the kid?
It ain't about how hard you hit,
it's about how hard you can get hit
and keep moving forward.
- Uh, that's not exactly true.
Boxing is the sport of
hitting and not getting hit.
Rocco is not the only boxer in the house.
This doctor is a boxer, too.
Click here to check that out.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
Click here, check it out.
(electronic music)
Who else do you know who
can box in office chair?
Huh?